[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله معكم ليلى الشيخ
في الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع واحداث
وتتفاعل اخرى هذه الصور مباشره
في مجلس الامن تتناول الوضع في اوكرانيا
هذه الجلسه دعت لها الولايات المتحده
وفي مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله
حرب اوكرانيا والخياره صعبه حديثا امريكيه
عن الحل السياسي مع استبعاد اخراج القوات
الروسيه في وقت قريب على الرغم من
معاناتها اوصل يقول ان واشنطن لن تملي على
كياب ما يجب القيام به ورئيس هيئه الاركان
الامريكيه يؤكد ان قرار وتوقيت التفاوض
بيد الاوكرانيين
يقول ان روسيا لم تعرض اي مقترح
الاستئنافاضه
وبعد مخاوف من تمدد الحرب الى خارج حدود
اوكرانيا بولندا تولين ان الصاروخ الذي
سقط على اراضيها اطلق خطا من دفاعات
اوكرانيه واشنط تقول ان نتائج لا تعفي
روسيا من مسؤوليتها الاساسيه في الحرب
موسكو تشيدو بالتعامل الامريكي وتدعو
وارسو لعدم التورك في ما وصفته
باستفزازاتك
يصير على ان الصاروخ روسي
بعد تعرض ناقله نفط مملوكه لرجل اعمال
اسرائيلي لهجوم بطائره مسيره قبله سواحل
عمان تاييد امريكي اسرائيلي ايران بالوقوف
وراء الهجوم مستشار الامن القومي الامريكي
يقول ان هناك احتماليه تنفيذ طهران الهجوم
ويقول انه يهدد حريه الملاحه والتجاره
الدوليه وسائل اعلام اسرائيليه تقول الى
المسيرته ايرانيه من طراز شاهد
في السودان بوادي روح الحلقه في المشهد
السياسي هو الحريه والتغيير اذن
ومجموعه المجلس المركزي تكشف قرب توقيع
اتفاقي اطار مع الجيش فتقول انه وافق على
اتقاء مجلس الوزراء مدنيا بالكامل مصادر
عسكريه سودانيه تؤكد التواصل للتفاهمات
وتقول ان بعض البنود ما زالت علقه ومسؤول
الاممي يجدد على حساسيه المشهد
في لقائنا اليوميه قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه نقشنا اعلان الرئيس الامريكي
السابق حسب موقفه من دخول سباق الرئاسه
المقبل في الولايات المتحده عام 2024
قائلا انه قرر خوضها وانه لن يسمح بفوز
الرئيس الحالي جوبا ايضا حديث علق عليه
بايدا بالاشاره الى ان ترامب خذل
الامريكيين من قبل حين تولى المنصب
لاستطلاع ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع كنا
طرحنا عليكم هذا السؤال هل سيتمكن من
الفوز بترشيح الحزب الجمهوري
الاجابات جاءت على النحو الثانيه نحو
اثنين وخمسين في المئه قالوا ان ترامب
سيفوز بترشيح الحزب الجمهوري في حين قال
48% انه لن يفوز بالترشيح
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز كيو ار الذي يظهر الان على الشاشه
لقاؤنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميات
الطرق هلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله عربيا
تتابعون في الحصاد ايضا مشروع قرار في
مجلس النواب الامريكي يطالب بالتحقيق في
اغتيال شيرين ابو عقله
[موسيقى]
روسيا لم تعرض على اوكرانيا
هيئه الاركان الامريكيه المشتركه
ان الجيش الروسي يعاني بشده
احتمالا لوجود حل سياسي واكد مليان نجاح
الاوكرانيين في طرد القوات الروسيه عبر
الوسائل العسكريه هو مهمه صعبه للغايه
مشيرا الى ان دحره كل قوات روسيا من كامله
اراضي اوكرانيا في القريب العاجل يعد
احتمالا مستبعدا بدوره قال وزير الدفاع
الامريكي
على الاوكرانيين ما يجب القيام به فيما
يتعلق بوضع شبه جزيره القرم اوضح ان امرها
يعود للاوكرانيين
الرئيس الاوكراني فلودي ميرسي من جانبه
قال ان الصاروخ الذي سقط في بولندا واودى
بحياه شخصين امس كان روسيا وشدد زنسكي على
انه لا شكل لديه في ان الصاروخ ليس
اوكرانيا واعرب عن اعتقاده ان الصاروخ كان
روسيا بناء على التقارير العسكريه
الاوكرانيا
الى احداث اليوم السابق ان شدت تطورات
الحرب في اوكرانيا ليس المقصود الضربات
الصاروخيه الروسيه التي استهدفت العاصمه
كيف ومدنا اوكرانيه اخرى بل صاروخ اصاب
قريه بولنديه على الحدود
رغم ان جميع الاطراف تنفست السعداء بعد
اتضاح ان الحادث لا يتعلق بضربه روسيه الا
انه يمكن ان يكون كذلك بالفعل في اي وقت
اخر
لقد اثبتت هذه البروفه ان الحرب يمكن ان
تخرج عن مسارها بمجرد ان يظل صاروخ طريقه
كما فعل صاروخ الدفاع الجوي الاوكراني
تفوقت روايه روسيا التي نفت مبكرا
مسؤوليتها لكن محال تبراتها تماما فسياق
حادث بولندا هو الحرب التي تشنها موسكو
كما يقولوا امين عام حلف شمال الاطلسي
وقبله المسؤولون الاوكرانيون الذين طالبوا
بالوصول الفوري الى موقع سقوط الصاروخ
داخل الاراضي البولنديه لا بل ان الرئيس
الاوكرانيه
ما يزال مسرا على اتهام موسكو بشان ذلك
الهجوم وحدها الولايات المتحده بدات
الاطراف تريثا في التعليق على هذا الحادث
الخطير وهو ما استحق فناء موسكو اذا رحب
الكريم بما سماه ضبط النفس الامريكي لكن
وزير الدفاع لويد اوستن اعلن ان بلاده
ستواصل العمل مع شركائها لجمع المعلومات
حول الحادث مؤكدا استمرار الدعم الامريكي
لكيف مهما طال امد الحرب حرب حرب تستمر
يومياتها الداميه في شرق البلاد وجنوبها
حاكم لوكا الاوكراني قال ان المدفعيه
الروسيه تقصف بشكل مستمر قريه
التي استعادتها القوات الاوكرانيه قبل
يومين وفي الجانب الاخر اكدت قوته لوكاس
المواليه لروسيا ان معارك عنيفه تدور بين
القوات الروسيه والقوات الاخرانيه في محور
مدينه سوليدار بمقاطعه دونيسك
وامانه الان من موسكو في دراسه عضو مجلس
الدومه الروسيه اهلا بك سيد فدرا اذا هذه
التسريحات الامريكيه الاخيره
هل توصف الوضع بالنسبه للقوات الروسيه على
الارض الاوكرانيه بشكل دقيق
اعتراض
تعلمون ان
الصواريخ
[موسيقى]
لان هذه
الصواريخ التي جاءوا بها لاوكرانيا
الاستمرار بالعمليات العسكريه ضد روسيا
اذا ما حدث هو شيء حشره
نفسها في الزاويه
عسكريه امريكيه تتحدث عن الصعوبه التي
تلاقيها القوات العسكريه الروسيه على
الاراضي الاوكرانيه
ما تعليقك على هذا الكلام
عدد كبير من القوات العسكريه
وزاره الدفاع اتت الى اوكرانيا بعشره او
15 بالمئه من القوات الروسيه
بهذا الشكل
90% من القدره العسكريه الروسيه هي
الصواريخ نوويه استراتيجيه موجهه ضد
امريكا
منذ عام
هي تستخدم لتحديد بعض المهام في المعارك
وهذا قد يضعف من موقف
قوه الروسيه التي لها مهمات اخرى في ارض
اوكرانيا
تتحدث عن امكانيه التوصل لحل سياسي
ما رايكم انتم في روسيا مع هذا الطرح
بالطريقه التي تقدمها الولايات المتحده
موقع
مستعدين لاي حلول
دبلوماسيه على اساس القوانين الدوليه نحن
لا نريد
قانونيه ظهرت بعد الحرب العالميه الثانيه
ولكننا مستعدين للحلول الدبلوماسيه وان
تقدم لاوكرانيا لقب مناطق لا تشكل اي
تهديد على روسيا لذلك نحن ضد ان اوكرانيا
خرجت بشكل غير قانوني من الاتحاد السوفيتي
واوضاع اوكرانيا غير قانونيه ولكن يكفي ان
لا تكون تشكل تهديد لنا الحل السياسي الذي
تتحدث عنه واشنطن يترك خيار المفاوضات
وتوقيتها للاوكرانيين
هل هذا الشيء تجده موسكو مقبولا
اذا اخذنا بعين الاعتبار ان 90% من القوات
الاوكرانيه هي دعم امريكي بالاسلحه
والمرتزقه
والمعلومات اعتقد انه ليس هناك اي هدف من
الحديث والمفاوضات مع اوكرانيا يجب ان
نتفاوض مع الذين شكلوا القوه الاوكرانيه
اينيته وامريكا والدول الاوروبيه هذا هو
الشيء الذي فيه معنى اما كون ذيلانتي
مستعد او غير مستعد لا نستطيع كيف
ان نعتمد على قراراته لذلك نحن لا نرى اي
شيء جيد في فرص التفاوض مع ذلك ونظامها
اما التفاوض مع امريكا واوروبا هذا ما يجب
ان نبدا به لذلك هذا الحدث بالنسبه
الضربه الصاروخيه في بولندا هذا همم رجه
الموقف الامريكي واعتقد ان هذا قد يعجل في
بدء المفاوضات
عضو مجلس الدومه من موسكو شكرا جزيلا لك
انتقل الان في ضيفنا من واشنطن جميل
الخبير في سياسات الامن والدفاع في معهد
كيتو ستفيد من اهلا وسهلا بك في الحصاد
اذا همم ضيفنا من الدومه يعتقد انه بدايه
تفاوض بين الامريكان والروس الموقف الذي
تم
تبنيه من جانب الولايات المتحده بخصوص هذا
الصاروخ هل هو فعلا ههه نوع جديد من
العلاقه خصوصا اننا بدانا نسمع لهجه جديده
ميسي
قضيه الصاروخ
تهمه بذلك القدر
بانه كان صاروخا روسيا لكان قد اثر صلبا
على اي مسار التفاوض لكن قضيه
لذلك اي اثر المشكله الحقيقيه التي تعترض
سير المفاوضات والشعور
الاوكرانيين بانهم يربحون الحرب ليس بحاجه
الى ابنائه التنازلات وحتى نصل الى النقطه
ان
الروس يصلون الى اعتقادا لانهم لن يحقق
المزيد من التقدم لن نرى ايه تقدم حقيقي
بذات التاثير همم اليس لافتا همم طريقه
همم قد الاوكرانيه على هذا الموضوع
الاستخبارات الامريكيه تقول شيء
بينمازيلانسكي يصير على ان الصاروخ روسي
الى اي حد هذه الطريقه هذا النهج همم
يمكن ان يؤدي الى نوع من
الحلحله التي تقول واشنطن انها تراها
قريبا
هنا يرتكب الخطا
الخاصه فهو يعرض موقفه امام العالم بطريقه
رده فعل امام العالم
بالصراره على ان الصاروخ كان روسيا في وقت
يقولوا فيه الجميع ان الامر ليس كذلك يعطي
انطباع عن نفسه بانه ليس جديرا بالثقه
ويبدا وكانه يريد الحصول على المزيد من
الدعم الامريكي ربما كانت ذلك قد يخسروا
بعض له ثلاث متحده وفي اوروبا كان نتيجه
لظهوره بمظهر غير النزيه طبعا هذا لا ادري
حقيقه كيف سيرجم هذا الى اي شيء في ما
يتعلق بايه مفاوضات
ضروسي ابالونه بان الامريكي اذا والله
اوروبيين الى حد ما بداوا يتعبون من الدعم
اوكرانيا وسوف يضغطون على زي نسك الياتي
الى ماده التفاوض لا ادري ان كان هذا
سيكون له اثر على المدى البعيد
في اللغه التي تتحدث بها واشنطن عن
الموضوع في البدايه كان هناك همم غضب
استياء همم شديد من الموقف الروسي الان
شيء من الغزل حتى كيف يفسر
والله
يعتمد على من هو المقصود في واشنط من حيث
الموقف الرسمي العلني ورده الفعل
لاداره بعض كان
متانزا هم لم يقولون الصاروخان روسيا ولم
يقول الرئيس
اي شيء
اتحدث عن نهج تفاوضي لم نكن نسمع به في
السابق
تدفع به واشنطن الان
سبونج بوب
بعضها ان
ادارهها هي بل تدفع الاوكرانيين الى
القيام بها ربما هناك تحرك لكن لا يبدو
وكان اداره بادر قد اتخذت قرارا واضحا
بانها ستضغط على الاخرانيين لانهم حتى
انضغطوا على الاخرانيين لقد لا يستمعون
اليهم وعند باك وواسطه ستجد نفسه مضطره
لقطعت عنهم هذا سيكون صعب جدا سياسيا في
هذا الظرف شكرا جزيلا لك سيد بنجمن
[موسيقى]
لاني لاشقه الاوسط حيث تعرضت ناقله للنفط
مملوكه جزئيا لرجل اعمال اسرائيلي لهجوم
بطائره مسيره قبله سواحل عمان
اضرارا طفيفه دون وقوع الحياه وقد اتهم
مسؤولون امنيون اسرائيليون ايران بالوقوف
في وراء الهجوم بينما قال مسؤول عسكريون
للجزيره من الاستهدافه تم مسيره انتحاريه
من طراز شهد
وفقا لبيانات موقع مارين ترافيك الذي
يتتبع حركه الملاحه البحريه فان ناقله
النفط باسيفيك زيركون غادرت ميناء سحار في
سلطنه عمان بعد ظهر يوم الاثنين وحددت
ميناء بونس ايرس في الارجنتين وجهه
النهائيه تشغل حامله
ومقرها في سنغافوره وهي شركه مملوكه
للملياردير الاسرائيلي اذن عوفر لما بلغت
السفينه مسافه تبعد 150 ميلا تقريبا عن
ساحل عمان اصيبت بقذيفه الحقت بها اضرار
طفيفه حسب شركه المشغل لها لكن دون احداث
اي تسرب من حمولتها للبحر وكاله بريس
ذكرتنا الهجوم تم بطائره مسيره مفخخه
واكدت وسائل اعلام اسرائيليه ان الجيش
الامريكي ابلغ الجيش الاسرائيليه ان
المسيرته كانت ايرانيه من طراز شاهد 136
مسؤول دفاعيا امريكي قال للجزيره هجوم كان
بمسيره انتحاريه وان سفينه تتمكنت رغم ذلك
من مواصله الابحار بعد ان قدمت لها
البحريه الامريكيه والبحريه البريطانيه
المساعده واجرتها تقييما للاضرار
هجوم وصفه مسؤولون امنيون اسرائيليون
لصحيفتها ارتز بالخطا الاستراتيجي من جانب
ايران وعلى وقع التوتر بين ايران
والولايات المتحده وقعت هجمات مماثله على
سفن ونقلات نفط في منطقه بحر عمان خلال
السنوات الاخيره عزيزه المخاوف على البنيه
التحتيه للشحن والطاقه في واحد من اكثر
الممرات البحريه الاسراتيجيه اهميه في
العالم
[موسيقى]
معنى الان من طهران فؤاد جديد استاذ
الدراسات الاستراتيجيه والسياسيه في جامعه
طهران ومن واشنطن كانت كاتسمن كبير
الباحثين في معهد الشرق الاوسط والمتخصص
في الشؤون ايران ودول الخليج العربي اهلا
بكما في الحصاد وابدا معك سيد فؤاد الجديد
هذه الاتهامات التي توجه لطهران كيف ترد
عليها
الايرانيه لم تتحمل المسؤوليه عن هذه
الهجمات نحن نعلم ان اسرائيل
ضد ايران مستخدمين وسائل مختلفه في مهاجمه
الايرانيين والايرانيون ردوا في فترات
متفاوت وربما هذه الحاله لا ندري ان كان
هذا
كان ردنا ايضا ام لا ايران لم تعلن
مسؤوليتها عن ذلك
في النهايه هناك يعني تقارير تتحدث عن
استخدام طائره مسيره من طراز شاهد ولكن
السؤال اييي السيد همم
كاتسمن اذا كانت يعني الامور بهذه الوضوح
السرعه التي
اتهمت بها الولايات المتحده طهران هل هذا
نابع عن تقدير امريكي اا مستقل الامن
مستند بشكل اساسي
ما تقوله تل ابيب
اكبر
وليس متحدث باسم الحكومه الامريكيه او
الكونغرس
المتحده لديها الكثير من القدرات
الاستخباريه والعسكريه في الخليج
الفارسيات مراقبه ورصد واستطلاع مستمر
المؤسسه العسكريه الامريكيه ليست بحاجه
الاعتماد على ايه حكومه اخرى
لتقرر ما حدث هذا الهجوم يتساوق مع هجومات
اخرى كثيره لا اقول ربما في الاشهر القليل
الماضي في العامه او اكثر الماضيه تقوم
بها دوريه على ذاقتي النفط
فطبعا هذه المره كان باستخدام مسيره في
الماضي كان في ما كان قوارب صغيره تستخدم
او يكون هناك هجوم عن طريق وضع الغام
لاصقه او عن طريق قوارب تابعه لحرس الثوري
تطلق النار عن طريق خدمات صاروخيه صغيره
الامر ليس جديده وهذا وهذا الهجوم
من قبل الامر يتحرر لا اقول يوميا لكن
بينسي والاخرى
حتى تستطيع
ان تعول على يعني الحجه التي تقولها دائما
ان الاتهامات الغربيه ومثل هذه الاتهامات
هي في اطار همم سياق تصعيدي اوسع هل الامر
كذلك فعلا
تتعلمونا فان السفينه التي تعرضت للضرب
يملكها ملياردير اسرائيلي اسمه عوفر وهو
كان ناشطا في كردستان العراقيه على مدى
سنوات وهو اغنى رجل في اسرائيل
وكان ناشطا في موضوع اتفاقات ابراهام
وجعل عدد من البلدان العربيه توقع هذه
الاتفاقات مع اسرائيل ولديه صراط وثيقه
التي اعيد انتخابه رئيس الوزراء قبل قصيره
اذا اذا ما ارادت ايران ارسال رساله الى
اسرائيل سيكون هذا الخيار خيارا مثيرا
للاهتمام لكن لا ندري مؤخرا طبعا الليونه
كان لهم دور في تنسيقي وترتيبي الاوضاع في
ما يتعلق بالاحتجاجات داخل ايران وبين بين
بينهم وبين الذين هاجموا اجهزه الامن
الاسرائيله لكن كما قلنا ايران لم تعلن
مسؤوليت عن هذا الهجوم لو كان لكن لو كانت
ايران مسؤوله فعلا فانه هناك ما يكفي من
المشاكل بين البلدان ان يبرر ذلك
ام لم تعلن هذا الحادث كيف يؤثر على الوضع
العام في المياه الخليج
ميكس 8
الحكومه
الامريكيه
طبعا الحكومه الامريكيه
[موسيقى]
فعل رغم ان كانت هناك
قتل ايرانيه
قتلوا في العراق لكن هناك طبعا هذه
الهجمات وغيرها قد تؤدي ربما المزيدنا
العقوبات لكن لا ادري الا ربما للامام
العلاقه بعوده
الى الحكم او رابط ذلك بالاحتجاجات داخل
ايران في ايران تحاول من وراء كل ذلك ان
المحتجون في ايران هم ممولون من الخارج
وهم ادوات خارجيه لذلك النظام الايراني
يحاول ان يبرهن بانه يتعرض الهجوم دائما
من قوى خارجيه في الخليج وفي داخل ايران
نفسها من خلال حركه
الاحتجاجات لان القاء اللون على طرف خارجي
في الهجوم يتناسب مع الصوره التي يعرضها
النظام بانه هو الذي يدافع عن الامه
الايرانيه امام الاعضاء الخارجيين طبعا
هذا كله
زي في زيف لان الاحتجاجات بدات بسبب قمع
النظام الشعبه وليس بفعل من الخارج
الوجود المكثف للولايات المتحده في الخليج
الم يجعلها بامكانها ان تسقط هذه الطائره
المسيره المترات شاهد لتحمي هذه الناقله
والله
الكثير من المعلومات الاستخباريه
عن طريق السيارات هذا امر صعب الخليج
مساحه واسعه
وايضا ممكن من السهل ان نكتشف وقوعه اكثر
من توقعوعه قبل وقوعه اعتقد ان هذا ايه
يعني اننا نتوقع الكثيره جدا
ليس بتلك الكثافه لتمكن من تحقيق ذلك في
الخليج شكرا جزيلا لك كانت
همم كبير الباحث الشرق الاوسط وتخصص في
شؤون ايران ودول الخليج العربي وشكرا
لفؤاد الاستاذ الدراسات الاستراتيجيه
والسياسيه جمع طهران من طه
وستكون لنا عوده لملف اخر مرتبط بايران
والحديث عن البرنامج النووي واخر التطورات
المرتبطه باجتماع مجلس محافظي الوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه الذريه ولكن قبل ذلك نذهب
الى السودان اذا ذكرت قوى الحريه والتغيير
جناح المجلس المركزي انها تعمل على التوسل
الى اتفاقا ايطالي مع الجيش وقد شددت على
انها لن توقع اتفاقا نهائيا دون موافقتي
جميع القوى الثوريه وقد كشف تحالف قوى
الحريه والتغيير في مؤتمر صحفي انا
الاتفاق الاطاري لانهاء ما اسماء الانقلاب
وتشكيله حكومه مدنيه كامله سيوقع مع
المكون العسكري في غضون 10 ايام وان
اتفاقا تفصيليا في هذا الصدد سيتم توقيعه
بعد نحو شهر واضاف التحالف فانا مرحله
ثانيه من المحادثات ستتناول
على الانتقاليه وقضايا اخرى كما قالت قوه
الحريه والتغيير ان الجيش وافق على ابقاء
مجلس الوزراء مدنيا بالكامل ونقلت رويترز
عن مصادر عسكريه سودانيه قولها انها توصلت
الى تفاهمات مع قوى الحريه والتغيير وما
زالت هناك بنود علقه
ثوره اكتوبر
1994 او ابريل 19
حقوق الانسان في الامم المتحده ترك فوركر
ان عمليه التسويه في مرحله حساسه مؤكدا
تشجيع التوافق السياسي كما حذر المسؤول
الاموي من ان الثلث السكان في السودان
يحتاجون مساعدات الغذائيه واضاف فولكر في
مؤتمر صحفي انا ما وصفه بالتراخي الحكومي
يزيد العنف المسلح وانتشار السلاح مؤكدا
رصدا انتهاكات قامت بها قوه الدعم السريع
في دافور وانتهاكات الجنسيه بحق النساء
ارتكب معظمها من القوات الامنيه ودعا الى
المحاسبه على هذه الانتهاكات
وقبل ان نوصل مع ضيفنا في الواقع من
الخرطوم والكرتون سانوتابع هذه الجلسه
التي تعقد حاليا في مجلس الامن والتي
تناقش ملف اوكرانيا هذه الجلسه بدعوه من
الولايات المتحده والمانيا
اكتبي
نوبي
مفوض الامم المتحده السامي لحقوق الانسان
اهلا بك سيد في الحصاد
وابدا بسؤالي يعني في هذا المنصب الجديد
وهنئك عليه لماذا اخترت السودان كوجه اولى
ثانوي
في هذه الوقت الحساس جدا
السوداني يعيش مرحله حرجه جدا
سياسيا اقتصاديا حقوقيا اذا هل التقيت
اطراف سياسيه من تحديدا ما الذي جرى بينك
وبينه
وزير الدفاع والعفو الداخليه والخارجيه
وايضا مع الجنرال برهان ونائب الرئيس
المجلس السياده وزير العدل وايضا التقيته
بالعدد كبير من مجموعات المجتمع المدني
كما التقيته مع المدافع عن حقوق الانسان
حقوق الانسان وبالتالي
لدي انطباع كبير
وكيف هو في الصداع حاليا ليس فقط في خرطوم
بل ايضا في الفاشر وفي دارفور
ربما الحديث عن
التواصل لحلحله في الموقف السياسي اتفاق
الحديث انه قريب هل لمست اجواء او مؤشرات
تدل على انه قريب بالفعل
نعم
الاتصال ساعيد السؤال عليك
اي مؤشرات ايجابيه تدل على ان هناك اتفاق
قريب
انه من المهم جدا بالنسبه للشعب السودان
ان ينتقلوا الى المرحله التاليه من الفتره
الانتقاليه ومن ما سمعته من الجميع هو ان
حقوق الانسان لابد ان تكون امرا مركزيا
واساسيا في المرحله القادمه
حقوق الانسان في كل احاديث التي اجريتها
كان في رسائل الرئيسيه التي سمعتها وهي ان
والقلتها بان حقوق الانسان هي تكون
المرحله القادمه
ولكن الحقوق كما تقول حتى يعني
تتوفر وحتى يكون هناك طريقه لكي ااه يعني
يكون هناك حد ادنى من انتهاك لها لا يجب
ان تتوفر اجواء السلام
والاطراف السياسيه الان تتحدث عن امكانيه
التوصل الى توافق هل لمست انت ما يبشر او
يؤشر الا ان هذا التوافق قادم همم
وبسرعه يعني الحديث عن 10 ايام هل هذا
واقعي ومنطقي من وجهه نظرك
تحديث انه من الواضح انه في كل المحادثات
اجريتها مع حكومه السلطات رعايه التمشيه
الامور وايضا من طرف الاخرى بان لذه
الجميع رغبه كبيره للتغيير والانتقال الى
المرحله القادمه انا لدي تفاؤل حذر بان
هذه العمليه السياسيه ستنجح في تقديمها
وتحقيق حقوق الشعب السوداني
لمست من الاطراف التي التقيتها في السودان
هل لمست ما يؤشر الى ان هناك بالفعل
شيء قريب ملموس ويمكن ان يستمر هذه المره
اخمن ما الذي سيحصل في الايام القادمه لكن
الشيء الوحيد لا يستطيع قوله هو شاهدته ان
هناك قويه
في اليوم الواحد وبالتالي هناك حاجه عاجله
الانتقال الى مرحله قادمه والتواصل اطار
عمل سياسي
حقوق الانسان
في الاتجاه الصحيح ما هو الدور المجتمع اا
الدولي في دعم همم الاطراف السودانيه في
التوصل فعلا الى هذا النوع من الاتفاق
من الواضح
السوداني
وان الحكومه الفعليه الحاليه كلهم عليهم
ان يبذلوا الجهودا كبيره للتواصل هذا
التوافق السياسي طبعا المجتمع الدولي
موجود موجود لدعم هذه الجهود ونحن من جانب
الامم المتحده من جانب ال ال
المفوضيه الساميه نعمل
حصول على حقوقهم ومكتب هنا بالتاكيد يقوم
بجانب المراقبه وتقديم التقرير حول قضايا
حقوق الانسان ولفت الانتباه همم
يقوم بشيء غذائها مع التاكد بان مستقبل
السودان هو المستقبل
حقوق الانسان الاساسيه
الى جانب ما تقوم به المفوضيه اسالك عن
دور الامم المتحده بشكل عام في ايجاد هذا
الاستقرار والتوافق المنشود في السودان هل
يمكنك ان تحدثنا ربما بتفصيل اكبر
التواصل بشكل كبير
مستمر
للتاكد من تقدم العمليه السياسيه الى
الامام
المختلفه في السودان ان همم يعني ربما
تندفع او او تتحرك باتجاه توافق همم سياسي
اكبر هذه المره
وايضا باشراف دولي الى اي حد فعلا هناك
استعداد لمسته انت على الارض
ولد
سابقا ان الوضع هنا خطير جدا في الاقتصاد
في انهيار المستمر والشعب يحتاج مساعدات
انسانيه وهناك رغبه كبيره بحصول تغييرات
وكل هذا
المناقشات الجاريه
الانسان
هي مستقبل السودان
[موسيقى]
حقوق الانسان هو في صلب عملك وانت اخترت
السودان تحديدا كوجهها اولى لك بعد ان
نعينت في هذا المنصب ما الذي يمكن ان
تخبرنا عن ما لمسته على الارض هل هناك
مثلا صوره معينه ااااه ربما
علاقه او نظره
اختلفت الان بعد ان زرت السودان عن ما
كانت لديك في السابق
[موسيقى]
ايضا اثناء الديكتاتوريه العسكريه كان
الوضع صعب جدا ان يكون سريع التحدث عن
نوعه حقوق الانسان التي يناقشها اليوم
وهذا فرق كبير اليوم المجتمع المدني
واولائك الذين
قاتلوا من اجل الحريه والعداله والسلام
هؤلاء انت كلهم يتحدثون عن حقوق الانسان
وكذلك السلطه
معهم خلال ايام الاربع الماضيه كان
الموضوع حقوق الانسان حساسه مهمه جدا
والشاعه ومجموعات المجتمع المدني
والمجموعه النسائيه والشباب الذي التقدم
كل المدافعين عن حقوق الانسان يعيشون
ويتنفسون حقوق الانسان يوميا وهذا ما يفيس
شكل لي امالا كبيرا
في الضوء الصوره الحقيقيه التي وصفتها
الان واا ملف حقوق الانسان في السودان
الذي يعاني ازمه كبيره هل هناك اي ضمانات
من جانب الامم المتحده لاربما
تحقيق او
للضمان هذا الاتفاق الذي تم الاعلان عنه
اليوم الاتفاق الثلاثي
لدعم ايطار عامه السياسي توصلون اليه
طالما ان يقوم على التوافق ما بين كل
الاطراف التي وافقت عليه هذا امر مهم جدا
الملكيه الوطنيه مهمه جدا اما الامم
المتحده فهي هناك لدعمه وكما قلت انا من
وجهه نظر مكتبي مكتب حقوق الانسان هو
متحده
سنتاكد ان ان
حقوق الانسان
مفوض الامم المتحده السامه لحقوق الانسان
كنت معنا اذا من الخرطوم في الزياره
الاولى التي اخترتها اذا كان في هذا
المنصب شكرا
مع السلامه
[موسيقى]
لا انا عوده الى الموضوع الايراني ولكن من
زاويه اخرى رافايل جروسيا المدير العام
للوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه يقول ان
الوكاله لم تحصل على تسجيلات كاميرات
المراقبه في المنشات النوويه الايرانيه
منذ فبراير من العام الماضي وهو ما يثير
الغموض كما اعرب روسيا عن امله في استئناف
الحوار مع ايران على اساسا وصفها بالجاده
في المقابل حضره وزير الخارجيه الايراني
من عواقب اي اجراءات امريكيه واوروبيه غير
بناءه في مجلس محافظي وكاله الطاقه الذريه
والذي بدا اعماله اليوم واا من جهتها قالت
واشنطن ان انتاج ايران من اليورانيوم عالي
التخصيب ليس له اغراض سلبيه
ذاته الملف ايران
كانما لا يلتئم مجلس محافظه الوكاله
الدوليه لطاقه الذريه الا لاجله
ثلاثه ايام من النقاشات تبحث في مدى
التزام ايران بتعهداتها النوويه وتعاونها
مع الوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه الذريه اجتماعه في الجنه
بالتحذير مما بدت لها مستويات عاليه جدا
بلغها تخصيب اليورين يوم الايراني
يقول المدير العام للوكاله رفاييل جروس سي
ان وقف العمل بكاميرات المراقبه في منشات
النوويه الايرانيه زاد من الغموض ويامل
الرجل مع ذلك في استئناف الحوار مع طهران
على اسس وصفها بالجاد
الى غياب الجديه تسند وقوى الغربيه
المساعيه داخل الوكاله لاصدار قرار يدين
طهران على منوال قرار الصيف الماضي
يحذر وزير الخارجيه الايراني من عواقب ما
يصفه باي سوء تقدير واجراءات امريكيه
اوروبيه غير بناء في مجلس محافظ الوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه
الذريهان يشير الى تاهب مجلس الوكاله
الدوليه لطاقه الذريه لمناقشه مشروع قرار
غربي جديد بلاده لما وصف بعدم تعاونها مع
الوكاله لا سيما بشان وجود مواد نوويه في
مواقع ايرانيه غير مصرح عنها قرار كذلك
اذا صدر ستعتبره ايران كما قالت بلا قيمه
الصهيونيه
سياسه الضغوط القصوى وتوجيه الاتهامات
المسوده المطروحه في مجلس محافظ الوكاله
تاتي في هذا الاطار ومليئه بالنقاط غير
الحقيقيه والخاطئه اي يصدر ضدنا لا قيمه
له ومرفوض تماما والمسوده المطروحه ضدنا
بهذا المستوى والشكل تظهر عدم وجود حسن
نيه لدى الاطراف المقابله
لعل الاشاره ستلتقطها الدول التي صاغت
المسوده وهي الولايات المتحده وفرنسا
والمانيا وبريطانيا
وحتما لن تخطئها وكاله الطاقه الذريه التي
يفترض ان يزور وفد عنها طهران لبحث
المسائل الخلافيه معها
بانتظار ذلك يتنامى التوتر بين ايران وكل
من الوكاله الذريه وعواصم غربيه هي اطراف
في اتفاق 2005 10 هواوي
واشنطن لاحقا تع اثرت حتى اللحظه جهود
احيائه التي نسقها الاوروبي
الاطراف الغربيه اشتراط الايرانيين اغلاق
ملف المواقع غير المصرح عنها قبل احياء
الاتفاق وتحثهم على تعاون تقنيه بشانها
لكن بنسبه لطهران القضيه برمتها مسيسه
ومعنى الان من الدوحه الدكتور فاطمه
الصماديه الباحثه الاولى في مركز الجزيره
للدراسات والخبيره في الشان الايراني
دكتوره فاطمه اهلا بك في الحصاد اذا على
خلفيه هذه الاتهامات الاخيره سواء من جروس
سي او من جانب واشنطن يعني هل دخلنا مرحله
جديده ربما اكثر تعقيدا من التصعيد في
العلاقه بين الوكاله وطهران
مكرره يعني اذا عدنا بالذاكره الى العام
2011 همم كانت مساله المواقع الايرانيه
ثلاث مواقع ايرانيه همم كانت حاضره قبل ان
يتم التوصل الى الاتفاق في 2015
العلاقه منذ عقود مع الوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه همم وايران علاقه يشبه
الكثير من من التوتر هذا التوتر ياخذ منحه
تصاعدي احيانا ويتراجع احيانا اخرى لكنه
في هذه المرحله بالتاكيد هو واحد من
الملفات الاشكاليه الشائكه التي حاولت دون
العوده الى احياء الاتفاق النووي ومنذ
حزيران الماضي عندما همم اوقفت ايران
كاميرات المراقبه 27 همم من كاميرات
المراقبه وهمم الى اليوم فهذا ال هذه
العلاقه تاخذ
منحا اااه تصاعديا سلبيا همم لان ايران
يعني اذا كانت فعلا تريد ان للاتفاق ان
ينجز لماذا تلجا الى هذه الخطوه
هي تريد ان تغلق ان تغلق ملف همم الوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه الذريه بمعنى انها لا تريد
العوده الى اتفاق هنا قضايا عالقه مع
الوكاله لانها لانها تعرف ان بقاء هذه
القضايا عالقه من الممكن حتى بعد توقيع
الاتفاق ان يعيد ملف ال- ال- البرنامج
النووي الايراني الى مجلس الامن مجددا
بمعنى ان انه حتى اذا تم العوده الى
الاتفاق فانا مساله العوده العقوبات مساله
موجوده اذا باقيه الملف مع الوكاله
الدوليه مفتوحه لذلك فان ايران بقيت تصير
على ضروره اغلاق هذا الملف الوكاله من
جانبها تقول ان المعلومات التي قدمتها
ايران غير كافيه وغير مقنعه ايران تقول ان
ذلك يستند على الى تقارير قدمتها اسرائيل
للوكاله وان الوكاله لا تقوم بعملها بصوره
تقنيه وانما بص
همم سياسيه ولاحظنا انه منذ مجيء همم
حكومه ابراهيم رئيسي وبعد النقد الذي قدم
للاتفاق الذي جرى في اواخر عهد همم روحاني
مع الوكاله
الاتفاق الجديد الذي جاء مع حكومه رئيسي
وضع قيود على العلاقه مع الوكاله خاصه
يعني
بالتفتيش بالضبط هذه نقطه مهمه يعني وهذا
بالضبط
اليورانيوم وخصوصا ان هناك طرف اخر الان
ايضا عاده للساحه وهو نتنياهو الذي يهدد
ويقول انه لن يسمح بايران نوويه هذا
العنصر كيف يلعب دور هنا في اجازه لو سمحت
نعم معك حق مساله تصاعد التهديد هي مساله
مؤثره جدا على صعيد رفع مستوى تخصيب
اليورانيوم وقد لاحظنا ذلك رفع مستوى
تخصيب اليورانيوم الى 60 بالمئه جاء بفعل
تصعد التهديد كما تقراه ايران لذلك فمساله
رفع مستوى تخصيب اليوراني الى معدلات اعلى
هو مساله مرتبطه بالفعل بحجم التهديد همم
كما نعرف او كما
ظهر فان المساله في ايران ليست مرتبطه
بالمساله التقنيه ولكنها قرار سياسي
والقرار السياسي من وجهه نظري مرتبط بصوره
اساسيه بموضوع التهديد شكرا جزيلا لك
فاطمه مركز جزيره الدراسات العامه
[موسيقى]
نقل موقع اكسس على المسؤولين الاسرائيليين
وامريكيين على قرار مكتب التحقيقات
الفيدراليه الاف بي اي فتحه تحقيق في مقتل
الزميله شيرين ابو عقله اتخذ قبل انتخابات
نوفمبر في اسرائيل ولكنه وزاره العدل
ابلغت الحكومه الاسرائيليه رسميا بعد
ثلاثه ايام من الانتخابات واضاف الموقع ان
البيت الابيض والخارجيه الامريكيه ابلغاء
الحكومه الاسرائيليه انهما ليس وراء قرار
فتح التحقيق كما نقل الاكسس عن المسؤولين
اسرائيليين انهم تحدثوا الى جميع
المسؤولين في الادارات الامريكيه واوضحوا
لهم مدى غضبهم وقال المسؤولون
الاسرائيليون انهم طلبوا السفيره
الامريكيه بتقديم تفاصيل لكنه نفاع علمه
بالتحقيق وقال انه سيستفسر عن الامر كما
اكد المسؤولون الاسرائيليون انهم طالبوا
الاداره الامريكيه بمعالجه الوضع قبل ان
يصل خبر التحقيق الى الاعلام وحذروا من ان
الامر سيتحول الى ازمه ثنائيه في حاله
حصول ذلك واضافوا ان وزير الدفاع
الاسرائيلي بارتصالا حادا مع مسؤول
امريكيا رفيع المستوى واوضح له ان اسرائيل
لن تتعاون باي شكل من الاشكال مع تحقيق
مكتب التحقيقات الفتاليه
اطلقت وكاله الفضاء الامريكيه ناسا صاروخ
ارتيميتس واحد الى القمر وهي الرحله
الاولى من نوعها لوكاله ناسا منذ اطلاق
الصاروخ بولو قبل 50 عاما اقلع اسال اس من
منصه الاطلاق في مركز
بولايه فلوريدا ويفترض ان يطلق الصاروخ
البالغ ارتفاعه ثمانيه وتسعين متر كبسوله
غير ماهوله يعني يطلقها الى القمر دون ان
تحط على صحه وينتظر ان تستمر مهمه هذه
الكبسوله 25 يوما وتحدث الى التحقق من ان
الكبسوله امنه لنقل لتواقي بشريه مستقبلا
يلا حبيبي
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ان هذه اللقطات والاغنيه كانت لاطفال من
مخيمات اللجوء في ادلب شمال سوريا رساله
بريئه رغم المعاناه رساله بطرقتهم وصوتهم
وابتساماتهم تقول ربما غيرت الحروب وظروف
اللجوء واقعنا المعاش لكننا نصر على
التعبير بطريقه عن فرحنا وان نكون جزءا من
هذا الفرح الجمال
[موسيقى]